Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday
morning podcast from Monday,
February 2nd, 2015. How
you doing? How the fuck?
Ah, yeah. Um,
I know what you guys are all expecting.
You guys are all expected me for to get
on this fucking podcast and to start
going absolutely fucking crazy because
the new England patriots won another
fucking Super Bowl and beat the loud
mouth green comments from Seattle.
You know what? There is nothing that
I would love to do more than that.
I would love to sit here and tell you
that I enjoyed every fucking second of
that Goddamn game.
But unfortunately all freckles missed the
game every fucking second to that game
I missed. And I know what you guys are
thinking. What Jesus felt. We were,
you kidnapped. Did somebody chloroform
rag you. What the fuck happened? Um,
what happened was is I booked this
fucking tour in Australia, New Zealand,
Singapore. I hope this is the,
he's not gonna be too loud.
I'm doing it on my fucking
iPhone because uh, you know,
cause I'm in fucking New Zealand and
I can't get any outlets to work and my
batteries don't fucking work. I'm just
having a technological nightmare anyways.
You know, I booked this
fucking tour back in November.
How the hell did I know the Patriots are
going to be in the God damn Superbowl?
I didn't know.
You know,
I'm one of the few fucking football
fans that actually admits that he had no
fucking idea what his team was going to
do this year. I had no idea. You know,
um, I can't fucking believe
you want, I just landed.
I was literally in the air the exact
moment the fucking game started and when I
landed it was fucking over. I
missed absolutely everything. Uh,
I'm obviously unbelievably psyched that
we won for a number of fucking reasons,
aside from the obvious,
you know,
more so than fucking excited that we won.
I'm just so happy that I didn't get
half to watch Richard Sherman run into
fucking Brady's face and
disrespect the guy again.
That whole fucking you mad bro thing.
I just, I don't know. You know,
you run it up to a champion,
the guy's got three rings,
you want a regular season game and you
treat him like he's a fucking rookie.
I mean, I dunno, I've never liked
people that do that type of shit.
I'm sure he's a hell of a guy to sit down
and have a fucking cap, a Chino with.
But I just, you know, all that
mug into the camera and shit.
I've already seen the highlights where
he did the 24 thing and all that.
And I'm sure that's another thing that
would have kind of ruined the Superbowl
for me was every five seconds they got
to cut over to him or his reaction.
I hate when they do that to Tom Brady,
like at the other team scores.
Then he got to see Tom Brady sitting there
with that. I'm mad. Look on his face.
It's like, I this, there's too much
fucking coverage at this point.
Having said all of that.
Um, um, so it's, this is,
this is still weird,
kind of like fucking excitement.
Like the level of excitement
I have right now is I,
I guess I know what it feels like
before the days of TV and radio.
You know,
we just live in the middle of nowhere
and someone walks up to you and like,
Ethel did,
she here we won the war.
That's what I feel like right now.
I got on a fucking plane and um,
yeah,
I missed the whole thing.
And I was praying to God that they were
going to have live TV because they had
sports bars down here that had the
fucking game on and everything. And um,
you know, I know what a lot of
you guys are going to see. Well,
why didn't you change your fucking flight?
Um,
because I am on the other side of the
fucking world and I can't miss shows
because of a fucking football game, be
it the Superbowl on not be the Superbowl.
Okay. With Tom Brady fucking cancel
a flight to watch one of my specials.
I don't think he would,
you know,
I don't want to get all Bronx tale
on you right now, but I, I, you know,
I got to fucking life. I
got to lead here. So, um,
uh, my God, I can't believe I missed
the fucking game, but, uh, pardon me.
When I saw the ending and
there was another fucking
ridiculous catching the ball
against your helmet and your ball bag
catch and it looked like we were going to
lose again, I literally would
have died a thousand deaths.
I can tell you right now,
I would have missed that interception
because after that fucking catch,
I would've been walking outside
doing laps around my house. Like,
you gotta be fucking kidding
me. Um, but anyways, uh,
I'm psyched that we want
obviously, and um, you know,
my condolences to Seattle Seahawks fans,
the real ones,
the ones from back in the kingdom era,
the ones that is still going to be in
your fucking stadium after Pete Carroll's
gone and everybody's fucking gone.
And you guys, you know, stink. Again,
the same way to patriots will stink again
when Belichick and Brady lead those,
the real fucking fans,
I feel bad for you all you fucking
loud mouth shit talk and fucking cunts.
Who were those lime green wigs?
You are the guys that I'm happy
that you'd fucking suffer that loss.
Go Fuck yourselves with your
stupid 12th man fucking shirts.
Do you know I heard Seattle actually
has to pay the college Texas a and M for
that 12th man thing that they
didn't come up with that, you know,
so they got to pay them and not to
mention the buffalo bills had a 12th man
thing, you know, back in the early
fucking nineties. I don't know.
I'm just so fucking happy that we won
and that, uh, you know, who knows.
I'm sure they'll fucking dealt,
measure the thread count in the fucking
towels that we were using to drive the
balls off with.
I'm sure Jim Irsay is somewhere trying
to figure out a fucking way to try to
taint this fucking victory.
I swear to Christ.
Did you guys see that thing where the
Atlanta Falcons maybe got busted for
pumping extra crowd noise
in? Did you happen to catch
that story? I swear to God,
if the Patriots did something like that,
we would literally be sitting down in
front of the fucking Senate. You know,
that was another thing,
another
reason why I was so fucking happy that
we won because I'm so fucking sick of
winning games and these
fucking cunts bitching about.
Yeah.
Absolute horseshit.
Okay.
At the end of the fucking game, I
mean deflate gate, the flake gate,
all of that fucking shit.
And nobody brings up how many people on
the fucking Seattle Seahawks team had
tested positive for steroids
over the last four fucking years.
Nobody brings up that Pete Carroll had
a championship taken away from him for
fucking cheating. And I gotta tell
you something. I don't give a fuck.
Yeah,
I don't give a fuck. That's
Seattle. Use Steroids.
I'm sure what fucking using them too
and whatever fucking Pete Carroll did at
the college level.
I know there's a bunch of other
coaches doing the same fucking thing.
So I don't know why people get
comfy with us, but who gives a fuck?
We won the Goddamn thing and I am
literally sitting out here right in the
fucking abyss. That's like,
I'm ridiculously excited.
Okay.
Like this must be like what it's
like to find out the Patriots won.
If you sit in and fucking Walpole
prison in like solitary confinement,
I can't fucking believe I missed it.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I'm sitting there watching
documentaries about cricket.
My fucking head phones won't work down
here. Nothing's fucking working. Um,
so anyways,
if you called,
if you fucking are listening this week
to hear my blow by blow Horse Shit,
you're not going to get it this week. So
I suggest you listen to another podcast.
But if you want to know what my fucking
Australian tour is like in the New
Zealand, that's basically, uh, I
guess what I'm going to be a Todd.
Can't fucking believe. What
are the fucking odds? What
are the fucking odds step?
Literally from the time my
flight started to when it ended,
that was the exact time
that the game was on. Um, I,
I don't know anything about the gang.
I really don't.
I just know in the end is that Seattle
was up by 10 points and for some reason
they're going to say that they lost the
game by not running Marshawn lynch in.
But I would just say that if you were
up 10 points with a quarter to go,
there's more than one reason why you
lost that fucking game. And uh, you know,
I don't think it's the worst
call in Superbowl history.
I think it's going to be called
that because it didn't work.
You know what I mean? And
uh, if it fucking works,
then he's a genius.
Let me talk about guts.
Everybody in the building is keying
on Marshawn Lynch and he dumped,
you know that that was going
to be the fucking thing.
I'm just so happy that the Patriots
didn't lose another Superbowl on some
fucking circus catch.
I swear to God after the helmet catch.
Well, I guess, you know, I didn't
actually mind the fucking helmet.
Catch as much as I met.
I was annoyed that a satay Samuel drop
that interception. Other than that,
um,
the 2007 Superbowl wasn't that bad because
I felt that the giants were a better
team.
The second giant loss,
that one was brutal
because fucking blew that
game. Um, we fucking blew that game.
We had the right call and it was Brady
to Welker eight yard pass wide open and
it bounces off his back fucking shoulder.
That would ice the game.
That was a fucking brutal one. But, uh,
that first one we definitely
lost. So anyways, there you go.
Now the championship for Boston. How
do you like that New York City? Huh?
Nine championships and like 12 seasons.
What do you got?
58 fucking teams and you can't even
do that yet. It's a fucking unreal.
Uh, uh, Jesus Christ. Why am I
shitting on fucking New York? You know,
I'm shitting on New York,
is it?
My fucking team won the Superbowl and
I didn't even get the fucking, see.
It's unbelievable. Unfucking
believable. So I guess I take the game,
so I'm going to have to watch it after
I do gigs in New Zealand and then
Singapore, Hong Kong, Mumbai, India,
and then I go to New York for
the Patrice O'neal la benefit.
Speaking of which last night, but when it,
what, uh, let me, let me just finish here.
Seriously. Do my condolences.
Tell to a Seattle Seahawk Trans.
I don't break any balls a little bit.
There's nothing fucking worse than losing
a God damn Superbowl and to lose it
like that in the fucking end.
I know it fucking blows. Um,
but you know,
he just got fucking,
well that ex extra fucking horseshit
hype about you guys being loud, you know,
got a little annoying.
So maybe I am being a little bit of a con.
What are you going to do
anyways? Um, plowing ahead here.
Uh,
speaking of the Patrice O'neil comedy
benefit that we're doing for the third
time, um, which I want to thank everybody
over the last three years who've,
who've bought tickets
because you've really,
you've changed people's lives
that Patrice loved. All right.
I'm not going to get into the details
of it, but like, you know, yeah,
this does charities on the up and
up. I just know that, you know,
we're not doing a show
with a pink microphone.
Um,
this is so fucked up.
Some people tweeted me so much shit about
awful commercials during the Superbowl
and I just had no idea.
I literally, you know,
I might as well have been orbiting the
earth and the fucking space shuttle that
that's like how, how much, how little I
know about whatever the fuck happened. Um,
I do know that it looked like a
hell of a game and uh, you know,
my heart said we were going to win.
I had a feeling we were going to win,
but my brain said that, uh, you know,
on paper we were going to lose.
And to be honest with you,
before the game started,
when I was thinking about it,
I had no feeling one way or the other.
I didn't have a bad feeling
like we were going to win.
I didn't have a good feeling.
Okay.
If we won by 40 or lost by 40 hours,
I I don't think either
would have surprised me.
I just had no fucking id on
this one. So, um, anyways,
I feel like I'll let you guys down because
I was doing this fucking Goddamn tour
and you wanted to hear me globe and
Shit. But, uh, you know, I'm not a guy,
I'm not a guy who fucking gloats
anyways, come on. I break balls,
but I don't fucking do dude.
I'm not going to fucking sit here and go
act like I played the Goddamn game, but,
um,
anyways,
and as much as I don't like the way
Richard Sherman acts when he fucking wins,
that guy is one of the best
corners in the fucking Lakey is.
And I wish she was on my team,
although I wouldn't like to watch that
fucking dumb shit that he does. Um,
so anyways, uh, like I said, speaking
of the Patrice O'Neal benefit,
um, last night I was playing
the, uh, the Sydney Opera House,
which was, it was a ridiculous
honor playing two shows there.
And at the end of the show,
somebody in the front row handed
me a shirt that they made, um,
that had Patrice, I'll take a
picture of it. It's fucking unreal.
It has Patrice on the front.
And then on the back is Patrice
talking to me and it's got Colin Quinn,
uh, Keith Robinson, Jim Norton
who have Robert Kelly's in it. It's
the fucking shirt is unbelievable. And,
uh, the person that front row just handed
it to me as I was getting off this,
you know, it was, I was getting off really
quick, so I just grabbed it and I just,
you know,
I handed them my setlist from the show,
which I hope it didn't come
off as a douchey move on,
just kind of getting off
stage there. And, um,
I didn't have a chance to look
at it until I got backstage. Um,
whoever you are that made that shirt,
please try and reach out to me on
Twitter or whatever. Cause uh, you know,
I wish I could have thanked you,
um,
personally for cause it's a fucking
unbelievable, uh, piece of work.
I don't know how the hell you did it
and I wish you made more of them. Um,
cause I know all my friends would love
one and it was just amazing. But, um,
anyways,
I'm about a week into this tour
of Australia and it has been,
uh, you know, just take it right now.
I'm thinking of all the Patriots fans
that are just fucking shutting it off
right now. Going, what the fuck, dude?
I thought he was going to go off. Sorry,
I didn't see the game.
Ah,
yes. Anyways, let me get back into the,
you know what I did do this week? I,
I saw some tennis.
Does that help you out at
all? This sports fans? I, um,
I went to the Australian Open,
I thought some tennis.
I saw Maria Sharapova and
the SMEs and I saw us,
Serena Williams, both winning the semis
to play each other in the finals. And uh,
if you've never been to a tennis match,
this is so fucking funny to be doing this.
The day after Superbowl,
I might as well be baking a pie right now.
Um,
if you'd never been to a, uh, to a
fucking tennis match, you know what,
just the level of wealth that is, they're
like, you know, um, you don't have,
first of all, the tickets weren't
hard to get like a, you know,
I just scalped a pair of them, you
know, I'm not gonna lie, you know,
they were like 300 bucks a whack, but I'm
like, fuck it man. You know, it's, it's,
it's one of the majors. I'll fucking,
you know, bring it up on the card.
I'll deal with it later. Right.
Fuck it. And when you go there,
like the level of fucking wealth that's
sitting around there and they smell it
on you when you show up the second they
see the fact that you're not wearing
loafers with no socks on,
they just look at you like you're
a fucking animal. You know,
you watched him getting
old boozed up and shit.
And I always get excited when I
sit around. Those people just said,
I just want to ask them, you
know, Shit like, you know,
when's the dollar going to collapse?
Like,
what's the insight information that you
fucking know? You know those people,
they'd like, they sit there, right?
They have tickets for the whole day
we just had for the afternoon. Right.
And it's sitting there and they got,
they were like the sweaters, you know,
where you're not wearing it, you just
have it draped over your shoulder.
You don't, you don't have a tied around
your neck, you just have it draped over.
I think that's the new way to do it.
And then not doing it like ironically,
like they have a sweater for when it
gets cold later when they're watching the
tennis. But anyways, we sat close enough,
um, and got, got to watch Serena right
before she won the, uh, the 19th,
her 19th championships.
So I got to do that.
I went to Bond Scott's
grave when I was out in, uh,
when I was out in Perth and um,
it was really cool.
They had a little bench there
cause I guess bonds, Ma,
mother for as far as I know, is still
alive. She's well into her nineties,
and up until recently would go down and
visit the grave every almost every day,
which of course is really
sad, but they, so they made,
they raised some money and they made like
a little bench for her and everything.
And uh, you know, it's, it's,
if you ever get a chance to go to
Australia and Perth, first of all,
purpose is the shit.
I talked to some woman when I was here
in the states and she tried to tell me,
you know, she was from Australia and
she was shitting all over at saint it.
Like it was, you know, that it was
fucking horrific or whatever. It's uh,
it's quite the opposite man.
Very impressive city.
It seems like the kind of place where you,
a
vacation or something man and beautiful
beaches. That was another thing.
Cool tools.
We uh,
we went down to the beach one day and
I quit laugh and fuck you. I know.
I'm pasty, but I had
to do it, you know, um,
and just to see the Indian
Ocean, you know, never seen that.
And I'm,
my wife of course went in the ocean cause
she fucking loves the ocean and I sort
of frolicked along the fucking
along the fucking beach.
I just do not go,
I went into the water just to say
I've been in the fucking Indian Ocean,
but I do not fuck with,
I just don't fuck with the
ocean on any level. And uh,
but if I was going to fuck with it,
I would go all in.
Like I would get certified to scuba dive
and the next time I come here I would
go to the Great Barrier Reef and that
I would do that before I would fucking
just start, I don't know, swimming,
align the fucking coast, you know,
like I guess that the sharks
come out in the morning.
They, they're basically
out when the seals are out,
so you don't want to be
out when the seals are out.
I guess it's early morning
and dusk or something. And um,
they,
they were telling me some fucking story
where there was a helicopter following
an 18 foot tiger shark.
Just keeping an eye on it to make sure
it didn't go into the beach area. I mean,
give me a fucking break. I'm not
going to that God damn water. You.
What's funny about the
Australia is down here too.
When they talk about somebody
getting attacked by a shark,
they don't say you got to attack. They
say he got taken and I was like, yeah,
there was a bloke got taken. I don't say
bloke. I came up the fuck they said this,
if you'd like. Some dude got taken
about 20 miles up. They told a story.
I don't even know if this is true,
if they just trying to scare a tourist,
but they were saying this fucking
guy was surfing and he was, you know,
not waiting for a wave.
He was in the wave riding the wave I
should say in the fucking shark and jumped
out of the water and grabbed him
like some sharp NATO shit. Like I'm,
he jumped out of the fucking wall.
I thought you had to have like your
arms hanging off the board and then from
underneath you look like a seal.
Sort of a strange shape seal or whatever.
But like, if you're, if you're
fucking on the board at that point,
if they're jumping out of the water, I
don't know. I don't know. Like I'm saying,
I don't fuck with the water, but I had a,
uh, I really had a great time in Perth.
Uh,
my favorite beer out here is that little
creatures and it turns out they had a
brewery and I was able to
go to the brewery. I could
have taken the tour, but I,
I don't understand going,
taking a tour of a fucking brewery,
looking at the, uh,
the distillery process.
All I look at is like the entire
time I'm taking this tour,
I could be drinking your product
fresh out of your fucking big silver,
whatever the fuck you call those things.
So a boost it up there.
Um, went over to bond Scott's grave
like I mentioned. And uh, you know,
it's funny when you get there, like
people all, it's kind of weird.
People leave like all these, you
know, bottles of booze there.
It's like the guy kind of died
from that, you know. I mean,
do you somebody overdoses on heroin?
Do you leave like fucking used needles
there? And it's really weird. But um,
I kind of felt bad when I showed up and
there was an empty Miller genuine draft
bottle next to bond Scott's grave.
And the uh,
the ACD,
not only the ACDC fan and me,
the beer lover in me wanted to
take it away from the grape,
but there was just something about
removing something from that place.
Just seemed a little a sacrilegious.
So I refrained from doing that.
But if you ever get to Perth,
they have this own little entrance
little gateway and you come walk,
he says Bon Scott entry or
something like that. I took,
I'll have all the pictures
up on the podcasts. I,
I did a retweet some this
shit. But you walk in, um,
very easy headstone to find.
And a,
if you look down on the ground,
they have like a lightening bolt,
like the ACDC lightening
bolt in the pavement.
And then above it is like
a looks like a record.
And then they had something else. I forget
what it was. Uh, which is really cool.
So it just sort of guide you right to it.
And um,
and then if you go over,
down onto the wall,
the water where they have the little
creatures makes their beer and shit a
little bit further up from that.
They have a statue of Bon Scott,
which I think used to be in the graveyard,
but they moved it because I guess
back in the day he was a deckhand,
a red decky as they call it down
here in Australia. So they, uh,
they put them down there on the water
and um, I don't know. It was really cool.
And, uh, what did I go from
there? Then I went to Melbourne,
I got there and that was a, uh,
that's when I saw the Australian Open,
did a couple shows that night.
And um,
evidently some comics came out
to see me throughout this tour.
I'm glad I didn't know
they weren't in the crowd.
That would've made me fucking nervous.
Um,
and I basically been putting
together my new hour out here,
watching this thing come together,
get my fucking standup
shops back together again.
It's going to fuck just been a great tool.
I really want to thank
everybody who came out and um,
okay.
You know,
throughout my time here in Australia,
this has been a fucking incredible to
come out here and play these big venues
and be adding shows and stuff.
Uh Oh.
Then I did Brisbane and um,
had a fucking, uh, I don't know how to,
one of my best shows I had in
Brisbane and then I got all,
I got pictures of all this shit. Sorry
guys. I'm a little fucking jet lag.
I know this shit isn't funny. I'm just
kind of go through my fucking tour here.
I played city hall. There was one of
the best looking theaters I ever played.
Literally you could shoot a fucking
special there. It was phenomenal. Um, oh,
here's what I got a funny fucking story
for you. All right. Listen to this shit.
So I'm going to fucking security.
Okay.
All right.
And they have the reg regular metal
detector and then they got the fucking
ex-ray one that I don't go through.
Yeah.
I don't go through that fucking thing
cause I don't give a shit what they tell
me.
Death thing is not good for you.
I remember when it first fucking came
out and people were opting out and I
remember people going,
look, Ooh, it's a big deal.
You already talk on your cell phone.
Like all that dumb shit that people say.
You know?
Um,
yeah,
yeah. It's like, oh yeah, so why
don't I get extra radiation, you know,
but I just add to it. Just makes
sure I get fucking cancer. Right.
And what did they say? They tried to say
that the thing was totally fucking safe.
And then what ends up happening after a
year and a half of radiating everybody
in my country too much,
they realized that they had the
fucking thing turned up too high.
And to this fucking day, when you
go through one of those, if they,
if a kids young enough,
they fucking send them around because it
fucking retards the puberty process or
something like that. But I'm supposed
to go through it, go fuck yourself.
So I always opt out and
I don't give a fuck about
your opinion on this by the way.
I don't need to hear your fucking opinion.
This is just my opinion. If you want
to go through the fucking thing,
more power to you.
So I'm down here in Australia and they
got the regular one and then they got the
fucking,
the bad one.
So every third person or whatever
it has to go through, whatever.
So I come up and guess what?
They want me to go to the other
one and it and I'm like, yeah,
I'm opting out and they like,
you can opt out in Australia.
So now I'm in this fucking thing where
I'm challenging authority in a different
country, which is always scary.
But I just said I'm not, I'm not,
I'm not going through it. And the guys
starts going like, oh well he goes,
do you mind if I ask
you why? And I go, yeah,
cause he used to work in a dental office
and I took fucking x rays and I put a
led vest over somebody before I fucking
took an x ray and I got cancer in my
family, so I don't want to
go through it. And he goes,
well you can opt out here plus the ones
down. Here you go. He goes, this thing is,
he goes, ecosystem only sees through
your pockets is fucking rent a cop.
Like he knows how this fucking
thing works, right? Oh,
just see through your
pockets. Really you fat. Fuck.
What do you know about anything other
than eating too many fucking donuts?
You Do, right? So I say to the guy, I go,
well we had the one in the states, they
had it turned up too high. It goes,
this is a different one. I go, no it
isn't. I go, that's the same company.
I'm not going through
it. He goes, all right,
well then you have to stand
over there. And I'm like, fine.
So the guy fucking makes me stand
over there for like 10 minutes.
Then this other fucking guy comes walking
over and he's got this little fucking,
do you know like when you don't like you,
when you get your baseball team schedule
or your hockey team schedule for the
fucking year, he comes over with one
with one of those that's like four pages.
Most of it is pictures and he goes,
if you just want to read up on it,
and I'm just started laughing like what?
That little kid's book you have there
that explains that complex fucking machine
over there. And he goes, no.
When he explains it, I go,
who to? Who explained it?
The people who made that fucking thing.
I'm obviously not cursing at them,
but they just said, you can't fuck an
opt out. It's a lot down here. Now,
if I had the fucking
time and the wherewithal,
the presence of mind during that
conversation, I should have said,
tell me what law it is.
Tell me what fucking law that says.
I have to go through that fucking thing.
Pat me down. We don't do that here.
Well you should fucking start
fucking unreal.
So then I ended up having to
go through the God damn thing.
The guy was actually nice. He apologized
for it and I just said, listen man,
I know it's not you. It's, this is
what it always is. It's not you.
You're just the guy here who has to
tell me I have to fucking go through it.
But the real cops who were making money
off their, who fly fucking private,
who never have to go through that thing,
don't have to worry about having their
entire fucking head all the way down to
be a balls in their fucking toes.
Radiated.
So is if there's anybody out there that
it has a fucking scientific background
and can explain to me how something that
can see through my fucking clothes is
not a, it's not a, uh, it's
not some sort of an x ray.
I mean, Jesus Christ Drinking
Coca Cola can give you cancer.
You're telling me standing in that fucking
thing head the fucking toe puts your
arms up. Oh, just shoots beans out yet.
It's just looking at what's
in your pockets. Oh yes.
Is that why you want to come up the other
side? There's an entire image of me.
Yeah.
I don't know. So whatever. So that was my
fucking big goddamn moment. Fucking fat.
Fuck. Make, make me stand there for
legs. Another thing that they do,
that passive aggressive thing is they
make you stand there for fucking 10
minutes trying to break your will.
No one that you probably
late for your flight.
I fucking hate myself that I didn't
say. You know what? Let me, uh,
let me see you at the fucking, uh, once
you show me the Goddamn fucking law there.
I Dunno. I'm sorry. I'm looking at all
these people's tweets now saying, ah
yeah,
April hope tour is going great.
And just from like my friends here
hearing good things about your movie,
black or white. Some of my friends saw
it sort of mom and dad. They liked it.
A Nice, nice, very nice. Hey, by the way,
can you guys please go go check out black,
black or white if you got a
chance this week. Uh, you know,
it's a really big deal for
me. Um, if you go and see it,
I made a lot of friends in that
movie and uh, Kevin Costner, uh,
kind of put up his money for the whole
fucking movie. He financed the thing. So,
uh, not saying you have to go see it. I
would really appreciate it if you did.
All right? It's getting great
reviews by the way. All right,
now write all your negative shit you're
going to say about I don't give a fuck.
Alright, live reads. Here we
go. Sherry's berries, everybody.
I'm reading this from down in New Zealand.
Sherry's berries.
If she tells you she does not
want anything for Valentine's Day,
what she means is,
is get me something for Valentine's Day.
Don't you love how this fucking holiday
is just so geared toward broads?
I just don't understand
this whole fucking holiday.
And I like how it's just about them.
What about their,
when they express their love to us,
isn't there that there's some somewhere
there's a fucking day and they
completely blow it off
because we don't give a fuck.
The last thing we want them
to do is to talk more to us.
Even if they're saying something
nice. Anyways, show her. Yeah.
Get down on your fucking knees
for the, for the, for the
big clam this year. Again,
show her you thought of something unique
and different this year and get her the,
the gift. She assured a love
Sherry's berries. Yeah. Get
us something unique. Her,
something that you and fucking 4
million other people are going to get.
Giant freshly dipped strawberries
from Sherry's berries started in 1999.
You know what they deserve? Sherry's
berries. 20 bucks. Here you go sweetheart.
Over 40% shavings.
Go to Barry's dot com.
Click on the microphone and
type in my code burpee. You are.
And from my left,
uh,
you can double the berries for just $10
more. Oh Shit. Maybe you'll get a gift.
God. No, she's not going to get you
anything, but you have to use my code.
Burr burs are additional copy points.
Choose one or two.
I'll fucking read all of them. Dipped in
white milk and dark chocolaty goodness.
Um, top with chocolate chips, decorative,
decorative swizzle or nuts.
40% off from Sherry's berries.
You just got to use my code burnt when
you ordered giant romantic, fresh,
juicy,
juicy want.
They don't even fucking so I'm just
supposed to use those when you,
I guess I'm supposed to. Giant Barry's
romantic berries. Fresh berries,
juicy berries.
Tell a personal stories.
Have you ordered these barriers
for you sweetheart? Now,
how did the berries taste?
I
how did they look? Did she like
him? How did your recipient act? Oh,
react.
Listen.
Fuckos there's only one way to get this
amazing Valentine's Day deal. Giant,
juicy,
freshly drips dipped strawberry starting
at 1999 or double the berries for $10
more. Visit [inaudible] dot com please
spell out the word berries. Okay.
B E R R I e s.com.
Click on the microphone at the top.
I already said all this shit.
Type in Berbee you are our
go to [inaudible] dot com
click on the microphone and
enter my code bur bur order today.
All right.
stamps.com everyone trips to the
post office are never convenient,
so why not get postage right from your
desk with stamps.com stamps.com even
gives you special postage discounts
you can't get at the post office,
including FirstClass priority mail
express international and more.
You'll never pay full price for postage.
Again. Here's how stamps.com works.
Using your printer and computer.
Buy and print official US postage
for any letter or package.
Then just hand your mail to the mailman
or or drop it in a mailbox that said
easy.
It's no one,
it's no wonder over 500,000
small businesses are already
using stamps.com I use
stamps.com I eed to send out my
merge from my shows, et cetera.
That's exactly what I
use it for right now.
Use My last name bur bur
to get this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage. Don't wait. Go to
stamps.com before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburbburthatstamps.com
enter
berm. How many have you got
left? Jesus Christ. All right,
let's blow through this next one here,
pro flowers.com look who's back.
Valentine's Day is next week.
Once again,
her friends are going to ask her,
so what did he get you for Valentine's
Day? Unbelievable. This is what it is.
All these big corporations
know that women are cheap.
They know what was the last well,
what the fuck the women have a bye guys.
Anything impressive? What
do they get yet? Huh?
What the fuck did they get
you? Jesus Christ. All right.
Impress your woman and her friends cause
God knows that means a lot to you and
you'll be a hero when she posts all of
all over his social media that you came
through for Valentine's Day
by ordering flowers online.
100 blooms of love with a free glass
vase for just 1999 oppressor and press,
or even more by upgrading,
add gourmet chocolates and a stuffed bear
for just nine 99 more.
And Go to proflowers.com you use my code,
burr pro flowers as quick and easy.
And delivery on Valentine's
Day is guaranteed.
Can't beat the price and the convenience.
You know what you can't.
And this is exactly what somebody does
deserves on this bullshit holiday.
Just go to proflowers.com and wrap it up.
Go into your two minute offense.
Get us some chocolate dip, fucking
strawberries and some flowers. Perfect.
I actually love this I advertising
and I totally endorse this.
This is exactly what you should
get thrown a stuffed bear too.
There you go sweetheart. And if she gives
you shit, all you gotta say is the fuck.
Did you get me? You know, exactly. Yeah.
Each is strawberry. Smell your
flowers and shut your face in tonight.
You're cut on one with the
bear cause I'm sick again. Um,
get it done early before it's too late.
Profile was,
makes it easy to check off the list.
Even if you already have Valentine's Day
plans, you still need flowers delivered.
It's a must. When she say she does,
when she says she doesn't need flowers,
she means you better get me
flowers or isn't that convenient?
Is that what she means? People who sell
flowers, how come it doesn't mean I want,
I'm fucking butter. Basted
a pork chop. All right,
go to full proflowers.com click on the
blue microphone in the top right hand
corner and typing burpee.
You are our,
that's proflowers.com click
on the microphone and type
in birth bur order today.
This deal expires Friday at midnight.
All right?
Sure. I'll get some shit about those,
but they don't understand that.
I know who you guys are in that,
that that'll make you actually
buy those fucking things.
You Know Valentine's Day?
What are you going to get her?
What's going to happen?
It's the stupidest fucking thing ever.
My wife is cool as shit. You know what
we do? I've told you this for years.
We don't go out on Valentine's Day
and we don't buy each other anything.
We go out like three days after a
couple of days before when food costs,
what it's supposed to cost. We
sit down, we have a nice meal,
we shoot the shit and that's fucking it.
I don't go to cvs and buy fucking,
oh, they'd fucking confetti. Whatever
the fuck it is you supposed to do.
I don't know. I'm in such a country moved
because I missed the super Superbowl.
You can't fucking believe it
and we want, goddammit, we want,
I'm so fucking psyche one on not
even winning. I just so site.
They don't have to hear
it from Seattle fans.
Yeah,
so site.
They don't want to listen to another
fucking Goddamn story about how fucking
loud they are and that and
nobody addressing that.
The stadium is built to make
them louder than they really are.
Fucking drives me up the wall,
but whatever. You know what?
This is the first 24 hours,
I'm sure Jim or say we'll figure out a
way to save somehow we were cheating.
All right, let's get into the
questions for this week. Everybody. Um,
wait,
am I told him I fucking stories.
I really don't have a lot of stories
about here being down here in Australia
other than the people are unbelievably
friendly. It's really relaxed.
It's a ridiculously
underrated place to go.
And um,
for tennis fans,
if you want to go to a great city and
if you want to go to an unbelievable
fucking venue,
gold,
go to the Australian Open and go
into the rod like fucking arena.
I mean
I went to the u s open like twice,
like 10 12 years ago and it's a giant,
it's for tennis. It's still a huge,
it's really big venue. And you know,
we were sitting up top and they were,
they know they were very far away.
This, this venue, I swear to God,
it felt like I was watching
it with 600 other people.
Like you could hear everything,
like Serena would throw the
ball up and if you know,
like when you throw it up
and then you don't serve, you
know, you just felt weird.
You just grabbed the ball to serve again,
he'd literally, here we go, sorry, sorry.
Sorry.
I felt like I was at her house and she's
playing in the backyard or something
was amazing. And, um,
I would say that Melbourne
is probably the, uh,
like if you're,
I dunno,
I would say that that's sort of the
New York City of a, of Australia.
If I'm going to get shit right now,
if I'm just starting to
try to compare to this,
is this is made knowing very
little about their country.
That seems like more like,
you know,
I don't know. We're all like a lot of
the, just where all the shit is, you know,
and you're not spoiled. New Yorkers
are, since they grew up in New York,
everything is right there.
So when they go every place,
they think every place else sucks.
I've kind of noticed that Melbourne people
kind of think every place else sucks.
Um, but, uh,
and I think Sydney is more
like a touristy place.
Both have their merits or whatever. It
all depends on what age you are, what you,
whatever the fuck you're into.
And, um, Brisbane was the shit.
I had a great time up there.
Beautiful beaches. What do they got?
The gold coast or some shit like that
around there. I don't know much about it,
but it was just a
phenomenal place to visit.
And I was actually a little
melancholy when I was leaving.
And also one of the great
things is when a comedian,
I actually started out with Al del Benny,
I got to uh,
he married an Australian girl and uh,
they relocated to Sydney outside
of Sydney about a year ago.
And uh,
he hit me up out of the blue,
asked if he could come down and hang
out for a show. And he actually,
I throw them on and did about five,
seven minutes before each show. And uh,
it was great just hanging out with him,
talking about the fucking old days,
trying to figure out how the
hell we became the old guys.
Like I saw a thing the other day that,
you know, the same like top 20 comics,
new comics to watch. So you
know, I'm a fan of stand up.
I want to see who's coming up. And I
probably knew like two of them and um,
and I was looking at him like,
Jesus Christ,
I've been doing stand up since all
of these people that they're shown.
We're probably like anywhere from
two years old to eight years old.
So starting to feel my fucking
age here. Um, but anyways,
um, a New Zealand and I missed
the Superbowl, you know,
if you're going to miss a fucking
Superbowl flying to New Zealand,
I got to think is a pretty good. Got It.
Thanks is a pretty good excuse. Um, okay.
Got To admit being down here and not here
in any of the Superbowl hype or any of
that type of shift. I really fucking
enjoyed it. Did Not miss any of that,
any of this shit. Oh, did you hear so
and so said this? Somebody said this,
blah, blah, blah, blah
blah and I fucking crap.
I'm so fucking psyched. I miss that.
And that's like that Mr Goddamn game.
Um, anyways, Australian
food. You know what's weird?
I'll actually do a recap of the Superbowl
when I get back after like February,
you know, and I'm back February.
Whenever the fuck I get back at, um,
I'll watch the game helped do a special,
I'll do a special podcast and bid week.
How about that? And I'll react to the
game. Like it just happened. Yeah. Okay.
That Jesus film. Anyways, Australian
food. Let's get to the, uh,
the questions here for this week.
Okay.
Hey Bill, I'd never been to
Australia. I've watched my
fair share of food network,
but I've never heard of
authentic Australian cuisine.
The whole shrimp on the Barbie thing has
to be exaggerated and I'm pretty sure
the only people who drank Foster's are
morons not living on that prison island.
What's the meal you've had so far?
Uh,
what's the best meal you've had so far
and can you give me some insight as to
what you think, uh, as
to what they're known for
down under,
down on that.
Thanks. And go fuck yourself,
dude. I have to be honest with you.
I am barnstorming across this
part of the world. I land,
I do a show and then I go to
the airport. Um, occasionally,
like today I landed in New Zealand and I
have tonight to go out and grab a quick
drink. And then tomorrow
I have to do the show. Um,
I've been doing a lot of press
when I've been over here.
I haven't really seen or done shit.
Um,
I've drank a lot.
What are they known for?
I don't know. The food over here is
great to see foods, obviously tremendous.
You know what they're
really known for over here.
I think they're known for their beaches.
Um, beautiful people, men, women
over here. Yeah. Fucking uh,
over and not over here anymore. I'm in
New Zealand, but they're fucking gorgeous.
But as far as the food was the best thing,
I've had a,
I got to tell you something, man. I've
had some French fries or chips down here.
Ordered Room Service.
This one fucking hotel,
one of the best order of French
fries I've ever fucking head.
That's the only thing that I can
think of that's, that has stood out.
Other than that, everything, the
food has been great. Um, but I mean,
I haven't had any fucking kangaroo
or any shit like that. I don't know.
I have no idea. Sorry man. MMM.
Can you guys tell a fucking jet lag?
Diane,
I really apologize for this
fucking podcast so far. Um,
El Camino looking cars in Perth.
Okay. Hey Bill, on last week's
podcast,
you said you saw two guys in El Camino
looking cars driving like assholes in
Perth. Um, I didn't say assholes. I said
driving like people who have el Camino's.
Um,
in Australia we have cars that we call
you and they are similar to the American
pickup, but more like a normal sedan.
Basically. They are mostly a uni body,
like car rather than a body on
frame, like a pickup. Do you know,
somebody tried to tell me that the pickup
was invented by a woman here and uh,
well over in Australia.
Okay.
But they used to have what the,
what they used to have like these
vans sort of looking to hell.
They used to call those things, uh,
God, my brain is mush this week.
Um,
what would those fucking things called?
Okay.
Begins with a p those fans from
like the 1950s but they had,
they had pickups in the 1930s I dunno,
whatever.
It had more like a van type thing and
this woman got sick of fucking back in or
something and having to like open the
doors and throw hay in the back and she
just cut the top off of it.
Somebody I guess from the states was
over here and saw it doesn't sound right.
Does it sound right to me?
I doesn't make any fucking sense,
but somebody tried to claim that they
came up with them over there. Anyways,
our division of General Motors is called
Holden and they make the commodore,
which is the current Camaro which the
current Camaro is based on and you can get
in the u s as a Chevy s s wait a minute,
our Camaro is based on yours or your,
your shit's based on our shit. Okay.
Don't get it twisted buddy.
We came up with the fucking car.
We invented the Goddamn
car. All right. Then we,
I have no idea who invented the
fucking car we flew first, didn't we?
Other than those French guys
who said they flew first.
How the fuck would we know
what you were doing back then?
We'd have to take a fucking ship.
Um,
well actually the Camaro was the 60s.
I Dunno.
Actually took a picture of a couple of,
uh, some muscle cars over here. Man.
It's cool cause they almost
look like ours, but they're not,
but they still look bad ass
and actually found a sleeper.
This fucking a mustard colored wagon.
Man,
that thing was bad ass a algae
also try and post that photo.
Let me finish reading
this thing for Australia.
Builds the Falcon a parenthesis.
The interceptor from Mad
Max was an Xb Falcon, uh,
which can also be bought as a u.
We have both these cars in
Australia for well over 30 years,
but unfortunately they will no longer
be built here anymore after 2017.
Also douchebags love clapped out
commodores to Hoon about in case they are
cheap. And pretty quick, there's
some Aussie slang for you.
I have no idea what the fuck he's talking
about. Bragging about commodores. Uh,
I know you're a Ford Guy,
so you should really check out some of
the Aussie Bill Falcons throughout the
years. Yeah, I actually did that.
I looked up and a check them out.
I was surprised how much longer
you guys built the Falcon.
I actually saw a model falcon
that looked like a fucking Ford Taurus
station wagon when it was outside that
little creatures beer place.
Um, he goes on to say,
and also if you have some spare time you
should check out the v eight supercars.
It's like Australian, a NASCAR, but
they race on a road course. You know,
it's funny,
I actually mentioned the corvette one
night when I was on stage out here that I,
I love the corvette and I was thinking
about getting one and people had no idea
what a corvette, at least the new
one, you know, they know what's,
I guess some of the old ones aren't.
I started just sort of
looking for Corvettes when
I was in Australia and not a
one, not a one. So, you know
what, if I lived down on that,
you know what I would get?
I get that new corvette,
z o six habit fucking shipped over here.
You'd be the only one on your block,
right? And I go fuck and drive around the
scare. Some fucking Kangaroos. Alright.
Australian woman bill.
I have a couple of friends who
studied abroad in Australia.
They all say that women
down down there are unreal.
What are your thoughts to make it fair?
Because you with the lovely Nia, uh,
you or she can comment about the
men as well. Fucking hilarious.
Uh, no good looking people. Tall, blonde.
Um, it's weird. Their eyes, their
eyes are you, they have Ozzie eyes.
It's weird. It's somewhere
between white guys and Asian eyes.
You don't like John Denver?
That's what I would say.
Oh Shit. That's what they got. They
got John Denver eyes with blond hair,
uh, Tan people, a really good
look and fucking, you know,
tall, blonde and 10, they get go. I mean,
I don't know what Hitler's
feelings were about Australia,
but I think he would have loved
it. You know, if he, if he just,
he's such a fucking moron that Hitler,
you know,
why didn't he just fucking take his easel?
Travel abroad?
You would have been interesting.
You would have had a fucking,
you would've had an accent.
He could've come down here and got
himself some tall drink of fucking water,
painted the beautiful beaches,
could lived out in a nice
quiet fucking life. Right.
But now he had to go for the glory.
He wanted to get into show Biz Dendy,
uh,
response to army guy from last week
considering marrying girlfriend to get her
out of the UK. All right, this is okay.
This is this guy last week who
was talking about, uh, you know,
he was,
he was joined the fucking,
some branch of the US armed services
and he was stationed over in England and
the only way he could get his beautiful,
perfect girlfriend over to meet him is,
uh, to live over there was if he fucking
married her. So this is what this guy,
this is good. The guy's
response here. Hey, burnout. Uh,
on the one 26 podcasts, there was a guy
you called me. Oh, burn it. B. U. R. R. N.
I think it was talking about the guy
who's going to get married, right? Hey,
burn out on the January 26 podcasts,
there was a guy who was worried about
getting married in order to get his
girlfriend to come to Europe with
them. My advice, get legally married,
but don't have the ceremony.
If you just need some
to show you I'm married.
This is a great way to
avoid the added stress.
If you explain that you love her
and you want her to be with you,
but you're not ready for marriage, she
will likely understand. Explain it.
You still have a regular wedding later
if you decide to make the emotional
commitment.
Also,
the issue of getting a prenup can be
brought up to make you feel more secure
without her thinking. It's a trust
issue. Waiting. What are you saying?
Get legally married, but don't have
the ceremony so you're already married.
Then if you're legally married,
does he need to get the fucking prenup?
I'll continue reading here. I was in
the reverse situation when I want,
when I wanted to get
married to my girlfriend,
she had student loans that would get
much more expensive if she was married.
So we had the ceremony
without the legal contract.
We were contact connected
without the added cost. Um,
later when she needed health insurance,
we went to the JP and
got her on the insurance.
Just separate the legal marriage from
the emotional one until you're ready, uh,
for the commitments they entail.
Thanks to go fuck yourself. Yeah.
But then if you're not emotionally ready
to get married and then you get married
to somebody legally,
and then you decide later that you don't
want to be married to them, then you're,
then you're fucked.
And there's no way to bring up a fucking
prenup without the other person going
like, so just exactly what he was
thinking of tapping out. Believe me.
Um, all right. Princess or just a lady.
All right. What do we got it?
Yeah. Uh, Bill, I'm a sweet guy,
so hang on. So hang out
with this girl. What bill?
I'm a sweet guy.
So when I hang out with this girl,
I often tried to be nice towards her,
either with compliments or little acts.
For example, sometimes when
we're just watching a movie,
I'll look at her until she sees me
staring and then say, she looks beautiful.
Yeah, I'm sure that's not creepy at all.
You may be gagging right now, but hey,
go fuck yourself. I care about
her. The problem is not that,
okay.
[inaudible] problem is not that she loves.
When I do that,
the problem is my gift giving a few times
now I've walked off campus a short way
to pick up her favorite dish
from her favorite restaurant.
The first time was because she was
busy with homework and miss dinner,
so I wanted to surprise her and the
other was when we were going to hang out
around lunchtime in our dorm.
I got us both something.
I got exposed to something.
Then I've also gone to the store when
she told me one night how she wishes,
how she wished she had this one
type of cereal. Oh Jesus, Gee,
I wish I had this one type of cereal.
And then you go fucking running down
the street like fucking mister McFeely
speeding. Mcfeely uh, how she
needed a blah, blah, blah,
some type of cereal and how she needed
to go to the store for milk and coffee
creamer. While I've only spent like
$30 total honor over the past month,
my friends wore me.
It's either going to get excessive
or lose its special touch.
I wonder if that's true and what should
I do, Bill and have a great day. Uh,
just kidding. Go Fuck Yourself. Ps,
she's not a manipulative bitch. Uh,
she's gotten actually upset that I
went all out of my way to get her these
things and she told me how she feels very
grateful but kind of bad about it. Um,
all right,
well first of all,
I didn't say she would never say
that she was a bitch. I don't know.
But all women are
unbelievably manipulative.
They have to be because they can't
physically beat the fuck out of us unless
they're like, you know,
taking that UFC shit,
then that's just game set
and match because they could
already beat you mentally.
Women can always be a guy mentally
because they fucking work on that.
That's all they work on. You know what
I mean? They're like a boxer, you know,
standing up, just throwing
punches and what do you as a guy,
you got to learn how to fight. You've
got to do all this other fucking shit.
You just become a jack of all
trades, master of none. Okay,
so they fucking do that mental
shift their entire Goddamn life.
And then they go down to a Dojo,
like,
can you imagine trying to fucking debate
a point with, with Ronda Rousey, how far,
how many on how many levels?
It would be fucking over as a guy.
She could beat you mentally because she's
a woman, so she's going to be fucking,
she's just going to weigh you down.
It's going to be over.
Or if she decides or you decided
to say something stupid tour,
she could then beat the fuck
outta here. So I mean, I dunno,
I dunno what you say that that's like
the ultimate fucking debate. I would say
as a guy trying to be a woman in an
argument that also holds a UFC belt.
Okay?
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
How many times would you have to get
your fucking ass kicked mentally and
physically before you
even found a weakness?
And that would just be fucking brutal.
Anyways, going back to this, uh,
first of all, dude, I dunno
what the fuck you're doing here.
You should never hang out with
a girl that you like. All right?
You got to get it on some sort
of, let's, I want to take you out.
You're going to ask
this fucking woman out.
You just going to stare at it and
just say, she looks beautiful.
Then run down the street and get her some
food that's not going to get you where
you want to be. Okay. Um,
you've been hanging for a month.
You're acting like her personal butler
and she hasn't said anything like she
wants to fucking get with
you. I mean, I don't know.
I think I feel like the window of
opportunity is closing because pretty soon
it's going to be weird if
you fucking ask her out.
Okay.
Um, I don't want to crush your dreams
here. I didn't know what your question is.
It says princess or just a lady.
What did you say?
Uh, well I do all that. Do I think
it's going to be excessive? Yeah,
I think you're going to be,
she's either going to use you,
which you said she's not like that or
I think you're just going to become
annoying or she's just going to treat
you as a friend and women don't have a
problem looking at you
just as like a friend.
So then when Sunday you go to ask her
out or try to kiss her or something,
you're really going to weird her out and
the whole thing's going to get fucked
up. So, um, I dunno, you know,
at some point when she goes, you know, I
wish I had some cereal. It's like, well,
you know, there's a 24
hour store down. Yeah,
the street might just give me some cocoa
puffs while you're at it. And you know,
something is rude as that
sounds for some reason. I Dunno.
They respected on some
level that you like.
Okay.
I Dunno. But most women, they just don't
want some guy that's just like, oh my God,
you're beautiful. Could I buy you stuff?
As much as they think they want that,
they just, they just look
at you like you're pathetic.
Probably because they know on some
level that they're fucked in the head.
And the fact that you can't see it,
you don't see any flaws. They just,
they look at you like this guy's got
and you just, his judgment stinks.
This is the guy.
Then I'm going attach my fucking wagon
to somebody with no goddamn judgment who
can't read people. And like somehow
he's going to bring home the bacon,
fry it up in the fucking pan.
I don't think he's going to do it.
So what I would say, dude is a, yeah, I
stopped being her food bitch. All right.
Does she wants to,
she should go get her fucking self and um,
almost think you need to back it off and
then you've got to lay it on the line.
That's what you got to do back off.
Stop buying your shit.
Stop fucking hanging out with, they, when
they run into would just say, listen,
what's the deal with us? Okay. Cause I
don't want to just be friends. I like you.
I'd like to take you out and I
would like to date you. That's what,
that's the direction I want to go home.
All right.
I don't want to fucking hang out with
you and go buy your smores even though
that's what the fuck I was doing.
That's the old me. This is the new me.
You see me right now. Look at me. Grabbed
my Dick Right now. Okay. Cause it's mine.
Would you care for some, you know, just
something like that. Sorry. All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody.
Can someone please tell me when
razors got so goddamn expensive. Huh?
What is the deal people have?
I been asleep for 20 years.
I was in the store the other day and one
pack of razors costs 20 bucks, one pack.
That is insane, but hey, sometimes when
you buy those razors, you also get a free,
you also get a free gift,
which is actually a punched in the Dick.
All right? Don't get beat up
with ridiculous razor prices.
Get your shape gear where I get mine.
Go to dollar shave club.com
everybody for a few bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing
razors and other great grooming supplies
like Dr Carver's,
easy shave butter,
a right to my doorstep. They're
planning starts at just $3 a month.
Here's how it works.
They sent me,
they sent me the handle for free and every
month they sent me replacement blades.
It's one less thing to worry about.
You can get deliveries every
month or every other month.
They've got lots of grooming supplies too.
You know that.
I love the one wipe Charlies.
I've never used them.
I just think it's fucking
hilarious and I love, you know,
I always said I love the shit
talking of one wipe Charlies. Really?
I got to try some of those.
Just fuck it off.
That's disgusting that you guys had said
to envision me trying some of those,
like taking a test,
like I'll take a shit with a lab coat on
and then just go one, one white, right.
God dammit they did it.
Uh,
why pay $20 for a razor when you can
get a fantastic shape from dollar shave
club.com for a fraction of the price
stock getting smacked around by rate,
high razor prices,
dollar shave club.com.
Raisers are Greg and they are a
fraction of the price. Trust me,
you wish that you had done it sooner.
Don't be a dumb ass. Shaves smarter.
Go to dollar shave club.com/burr
dollar shave club.com/burr all right,
lastly, but certainly not
leastly. I got two more here.
The National Academy of Sports Medicine,
they are here.
New Year's resolutions.
Everyone's got one, get in shape,
be healthy or get a new job.
Become a certified personal trainer with
the National Academy of Sports Medicine
and you can do all three.
The fitness industry is booming and the
demand for personal trainers is soaring.
Imagine waking up every day excited
to get to work, not to a job,
but a rewarding career,
getting paid to stay in shape while
helping others reach their fitness goals.
You'll set your own hours, work
in health clubs, sports clinics,
and corporate wellness, and you'll
love who you work with. Finally,
do what you truly enjoy
and get paid for it.
Get a headstart on 2015 and begin your
certification with the National Academy
of Sports Medicine.
Now,
if you don't land a job as a personal
trainer within 60 days is certification,
they'll give you your
money back guaranteed.
Go To my USA trainer.com for free.
Excuse me for a free 14 day sneak peek
of their fast and fun online program.
That's my us trainer.com minus my
USA trainer.com restrictions apply.
Visit my USA trainer.com for details,
legal zoom.com everybody,
uh,
what's your New Year's resolution?
Jesus Christ was doing this again.
If you're like me, it's getting your
life organized. Stop speaking for me.
My New Year's resolution is
to stop losing my shit. Okay,
legal zoom anyways, but I'm sure
somebody says to get organized,
where do you begin?
A great place to start is protecting your
family and a great way to take control
of your family's future is
with a will or living trust.
That's where legal zoom can help.
There's no easier way to get to make sure
your family is legally taken care of.
Getting your life organized also means
taking control of your financial affairs.
So if you're thinking of starting a
business or if you already have one,
legal zoom can help you form your business
and provide the support you need to
run it successfully
for more than 10 years.
Legal Zoom has helped millions of people
get personalized personalized attention
that they need and if
you'd like more help,
they can connect you with an
independent attorney in most states,
but they are not a law firm this month.
You can save even more by entering bird
bur in the referral box at checkout.
That's Promo Code Bur bur don't
let another year pass a pass.
You by before getting your life organized
for legal help. You can count on your,
that you can count on for
your family or small business.
Go to legalzoom.com Promo
Code [inaudible], B, u. R.
R. All right, they get go.
Mercifully the advertising is
done for the fucking day. Um,
what do we got left here?
I think I ran out.
I had got damn and I read all the fucking
questions for the week, right at 59.
Look at that. Um, once again,
congratulations to the New England
patriots sets the podcast for this week.
Uh, you know, beyond being a fan,
I'm really happy for a Tom Brady and
bill Belichick a grant to get his first
one, the defense and all those guys
to get their fucking rings. It's just,
it's just awesome. And uh, you know, whose
kidney with Tom last, this fucking one.
Then you'd be three and three and all
the fucking jerk offs would be seen a
bunch of shit about them.
And to be honest,
this is six Superbowls in a row.
This guy drove from behind for
the winning fucking touchdown.
It ain't his fault. Well
actually, no, I can't say that.
The last one that's wrote a Welker,
I dunno.
I don't know who to blame on that
one. But, um, five out of six,
this guy is always doing the fucking deed.
So it's so psyched that the
defense finally stepped up
and I don't even know the
name of the guy that picked off the ball.
I never even fucking heard of them.
I read his name. I had
no idea. So, uh, anyways,
my apology to the sports fans that listen
to this fucking podcast because, uh,
I did not see the God damn game. I can't
fucking believe it. Um, but anyways,
I'm looking forward to my time
down here in New Zealand, um,
work in Auckland tomorrow night and
I'm working a Wellington and then I go,
then I go to fucking Southeast Asia.
Man,
can you fucking believe that
I'm going to be going to Asia?
And I already had an an amazing interview
as far as like just talking to this
guy from Hong Kong and uh,
I'm really looking forward to meeting
comics in Singapore or Hong Kong and India
just to hear their,
you know,
cause the scenes is so new over
there and that type of stuff,
it's fucking ridiculous. You know, I
did a podcast this week out of India.
These guys, two guys called me
up, right. Fucking hilarious.
Guiding India is going to be fucking
hilarious because Indian people seem like
my favorite kind of comic where my
nothing I like better than somebody who's
really smart,
but they're fucking silly.
And these guys in this podcast for like
that as they tried to trick me to get in
talking about the fucking government,
um,
when they didn't have the fucking
balls to or whatever, they,
they weren't going to do what they tried
to get me in trouble over there. Man.
It's fucking hilarious.
When I called him out on it,
they fucking laugh their asses off.
It was like,
it was like talking to fucking rich
vos is some shit from over there.
Men that same kind of ball buster. And so
I'm just really looking forward to, uh,
to that I think it's going to be life
changing. And, uh, and then once again,
when I, after I'm done with
this, this whirlwind tour here,
I flied from India over
to Dubai connecting Dubai
and then I go to New York.
So I will literally have
flown around the world,
which is an unbelievable
privilege to be able to do that.
So I really want to take the time to
thank everybody who sent me emails telling
me to come over to these places
because it's definitely a life changing
experience. And, um, you know,
I ran into a bunch of Indian comics at
the laugh factory maybe like four years
ago or something, three years ago.
I can't even tell at this point.
And they actually, you know, knew what my,
knew my stuff and said that there was
people over there that would come see the
show.
And that's all I need to say.
And I'll fucking figure out a way to
get over there. And, uh, I actually,
when I did that podcast, like
they were talking about, you know,
they asked me about the Philly
thing when I got booed, I was like,
you fucking guys saw that
over there. They're like,
yeah, you know, we do comedy.
You know, we fucking watch this
shit. So it's a pretty humbling that.
So I'm looking forward to it,
going to get some dumplings in Hong Kong.
I want to get some fucking,
you know, it's funny, I,
I'm going to ask the people in
India where should I go eat?
And I was just thinking they're
probably sick of Indian food. You know,
they're probably going to take me to
a Sushi joint or something like that.
Cause you know,
I want to go over there and get some
fucking the best Indian food I ever had.
So hopefully that's where
they're going to take me. But uh,
I'm really looking forward to it.
You know,
a lot more shows to do a lot more whiskey
to drink and I'll do, do you know,
they don't fucking have any
cigar bars in Australia.
That's what this fucking guy told me.
And when you go to buy the Cuban cigars,
I made a video. I got to show you this,
like how fucking hardcore they are.
I bought a Cuban cigar and you had to
sit outside like a fucking animal smoking
this thing outside.
Like I smoked a cigar the way Paul
Versey smokes a cigar standing out in the
street next to a trashcan.
Uh, anyways, I don't know
what to tell you. Uh,
thanks for listening to
the podcast. That's it.
Congratulations to the Patriots,
ed. Seriously, I'm not joking. Condolences
to the Seattle Seahawks fans. I know.
What the fuck that feels like to have
a crushing goddamn defeat. But uh,
you'll be back next year.
You know,
you're gonna fucking great
team and fucking organization
and I don't give a fuck
that you stadium makes you louder
and that some of your players did.
Roids I don't give a fuck about that
shit cause everybody's fucking doing that
shit right. There you go. God
bless you. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.